un élément supplémentaire à verser s'il
était nécessaire à ce dossier de la
décrispation c'est l'interview forte
apaisante donné hier au monde par
monsieur chevènement
le ministre de l'éducation et adopte un
profil bas pour évoquer les rapports du
public et du privé
une attitude qui inquiète un peu les
partisans de l'école laïque qui
attendent toutefois d'en savoir plus
comme expliqué tout à l'heure michel
bouchard et ça ce qui est leur chef de
file
je n'ai pas aperçu de nouveau climat il
ya un nouveau ministre il ya des
perspectives qui restent à définir nous
serons très attentifs à ce qu'elles
seront en tout cas et pour conclure ce
n'est pas nous qui renoncerions en quoi
que ce soit aux grands objectifs
généreux qui sont ceux de l'unification
laïque qui sont ceux du développement du
système éducatif mais compte tenu de
tout ce qui s'est passé disons que nous
éprouvons une certaine méfiance en tout
cas expectative celle déclarations
tranchent avec toute une série
d'événements qui incontestablement à
modifier le climat éducatif la polémique
a fait place à une certaine décrispation
après le retrait de la loi savary et le
changement de gouvernance premier acte
la déclaration de pierre daniel
président des parents d'élèves de
l'enseignement libre qui contrairement à
l'opposition
déclare être style au référendum sur
l'école je crois qu'avant de parler
référendum sur l'école il s'agit d'abord
de trouver les accords et les pistes
d'accord qui serait possible dans les
mois à venir avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale je le suis
beaucoup plus orienté vers un accord de
ce type que vers un référendum sur
l'école une semaine plus tard c'est le
socialiste andré laignel chef de file
des laïcs qui n'exige plus la
titularisation des maîtres du privé nous
avions toujours dit que nous voulions
cette intégration par négociation la
négociation et fruits l'école privée ne
veut pas de cette chance historique qui
lui était offerte de faire un grand
service public laïque et unifiée de
l'éducation nationale elle préfère une
logique séparatiste
intellectuellement je crois que c'est
une faute une erreur pour elle mais nous
en prenons acte
il n'est pas question de contrat à
partir de là il s'agit d'assurer les
libertés ce changement de climat se
confirme avec une interview au journal
du dimanche du père guiberteau
secrétaire général de l'enseignement
catholique en nettement ses distances
avec les hommes politiques de
l'opposition fin le ministre de
l'éducation nationale dans une interview
au journal le monde
las entente qu'il n'y aura pas de loi
chevènement la laïcité dit-il c'est
avant tout le combat contre l'ignorance
bref le comité national d'action laïque
dans ce débat semble aujourd'hui quelque
peu isolé reste à savoir si les
militants laïques
les enseignants du ps et ils sont
nombreux penche pour la modération ou
soutiennent les thèses du cnal